well here are the nominees for Best
Original Screenplay frozen river by
Courtney Hunt happy-go-lucky by Mike Lee
in Bruges by Martin McDonagh milk by
Dustin Lance Black Wally's screenplay by
Andrew Stanton Jim Reardon original
story by Andrew Stanton Pete docter
and the Oscar goes to Dustin Lance Rock
and milk
oh my god this was um this is not an
easy film to make and first off I have
to thank Cleve Jones and Anne kronenberg
and all the real-life people who shared
their stories with me and um Gus Van
Sant's Sean Penn Emil Hurst Josh Brolin
James Franco and our entire cast my
producers Dan Jenks and Bruce Cohen
everyone at grounds won't focus for
taking on the challenge of telling this
life-saving story when I was 13 years
old my beautiful mother and my father
moved me from a conservative Mormon home
in San Antonio Texas to California and I
heard the story of Harvey Milk and it
gave me hope it gave me the hope to live
my life it gave me the hope to one day I
could live my life openly is Who I am
and that maybe even I could fall in love
and one day get married I want to I want
to thank my mom who has always loved me
for who I am even when there was
pressure not to but most of all if
Harvey had not been taken from us 30
years ago I think he'd want me to say to
all of the gay and lesbian kids out
there tonight who have been told that
they are less than by their churches by
the government or by their families that
you are beautiful wonderful creatures of
a value and that no matter what anyone
tells you God does love you and that
very soon I promise you you will have
equal rights federally across this great
nation of ours
thank you thank you and thank you God
for giving us Harvey Milk
you